Elizabeth Warren collapses in the polls
as Peabody judge comes under fire the
media check into the gender of a dog at
the White House in America's life
expectancy drops again i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show the ben
shapiro show is sponsored by expressvpn
stand up for your digital rights visit
expressvpn calm /ban well it has been a
rough week for Elizabeth Warren ruff
several weeks for Elizabeth Warren ever
since she started actually releasing
details of her plans and people realized
that these plans were incredibly stupid
her poll numbers have just been in
freefall and you've seen this in Iowa
you seen this in New Hampshire as well
she has now dropped behind several
candidates in New Hampshire according to
the Real Clear Politics polling average
so according to Real Clear Politics
right now she is trailing in Iowa two
people who to judge she is also trailing
in New Hampshire not only due to judge
but also to Bernie Sanders according to
the most recent poll there's a New
Hampshire poll today that has Sanders of
26 blue to judge at 22 and Warren and
Biden tied at 14 which is a disaster
area
for Elizabeth Warren she's running in
third in New Hampshire according to the
RCP poll average behind both Budaj and
Sanders in Iowa she's also running third
behind both Budaj and Sanders a disaster
disaster area for Elizabeth Warren
without a doubt and the latest polls
show that she has also dropped
nationally down to third she's down to
third nationally with peabody judge
rising into double digits in the RCP
polling average Biden remains at 28% in
the RCP polling average Sanders at 18%
Warren at 17% Budaj at 11% and in the
latest polling numbers from Quinnipiac
she is utterly falling apart according
to Yahoo News Budaj
the moderate millennial mayor of South
Bend Indiana moderate leapfrogged the
races may no liberal candidates Warren
and fellow senator Bernie Sanders to
claim second behind the resilient
national leader Joe Biden according to
Quinnipiac University's latest poll
Biden is still ahead with 24% among
Democratic voters and independents who
lean Democrat a rise of three percentage
points a reclaiming of the poll position
since Quinnipiac last poll on October
24th when he trailed Warren Budaj edged
jumped from 10% to 16% in that time
frame
Warren's support dropped from 28% to 14%
which is just an utterly enormous in
Logan Sanders is down from 16% to 13% so
full-on disaster area for Elizabeth
Warren she has got to be in a state of
utter panic meanwhile she tries to
whistle past the graveyard
she's been suggesting that she'll choose
a woman as VP well lady you're not gonna
be the nominee so I'm not sure that this
is gonna matter here's Elizabeth Warren
do anything I'm the I am woman hear me
lecture you first it would be entirely
presumptuous of me to talk about running
mates I'm out here talking about why I'm
running for president and asking for all
of you to get out and caucus for me
that's how I'm gonna end this I'm gonna
ask you to get out the caucus for me but
I gotta say why wouldn't I have a woman
for a running mate
why wouldn't you have a woman for a
running mate because you're not gonna be
the presidential nominee that's why
you're not gonna have a woman a woman
for a running mate by the way someone I
get this frequently on my sort of public
email address very very kind folks on
the left well sign me up to the mailing
lists of places like Planned Parenthood
and as it turns out the Elizabeth Warren
campaign and I received this email from
senator Warren today quote thanks for
being a part of the conversation about
how we can make big structural change in
our country for Elizabeth the fight to
level the playing field for working
families is personal when she was
growing up in Oklahoma her family barely
hung on by their fingernails her dad had
a heart attack when she was 12 and her
mom saved their home by getting a
minimum-wage job answering the phones at
Sears Elizabeth graduated from a public
commuter college that cost 50 bucks a
semester and it opened a million doors
for her she went on to become a public
school teacher of law professor u.s.
senator and now a presidential candidate
because she grew up at a time when
America invested in kids like her okay
so this is why her pitch falls flat this
is a lady who really has had a pretty
wonderful American life moaning about
how terrible America is and let me just
note the timeline here she's now 70
years old so her dad had a heart attack
when she was 12 that means that her dad
had a heart attack in 1961 and her
suggestion is that the federal
government spends less in terms of
resources now than they did in 1961
which is patently absurd that's even
before the Great Society programs right
none of that makes any sense whatsoever
when she suggests that her mom saved
their home by getting a minimum wage job
answering the phones at Sears was the
minimum wage higher or lower back in
1961 when she suggests that she
graduated from a public commune
that cost fifty bucks a semester yes
because that is not inflation in just
adjusted from 1967 also there are public
commuter colleges they still exist so
the the entire pitch that she is making
that somehow America has grown crueler
that somehow America has has grown less
less spendthrift less willing to spend
on the American public is just untrue
the government is spending four trillion
dollars a year we're running a one
trillion dollar a year deficit we're
spending more than we ever have it is
not close and yet Elizabeth Warren is
trying to maintain that she had it
better in 1961 and at the same time
suggesting that the governing system in
1961 was somehow much better than it is
now which again I'm gonna have to call
BS on that one because it's absolute
nonsense so Warren is completely falling
apart and the more people see of her the
less they like her well now the question
becomes will the same thing happen to
people who to judge so the press are out
to get booted judge now they do not want
putti judge to be the nominee they were
they were in love with Elizabeth Warren
she made them feel good about themselves
Buddha judge makes them feel okay about
themselves but not as great as they
could because the fact is that Buddha
judge has only gained momentum again by
pushing back to the center again he
launched his campaign as a sort of
centrist alternative to Bernie Sanders
and then he skewed way to the left and
started calling all Christians bad
Christians if they supported traditional
marriage and now he is skewed back to
the center and he has fought against
Elizabeth Warren on that basis and
gained polling credibility by the way
you wonder why cory booker is staking
the race why Amy Klobuchar is staying in
the race the answer is because everybody
in the Democratic field at this point
has to understand that this is now a
revolving wheel it's the wheel of
fortune and wherever that wheel stops
you may be the next leader in the polls
they've already gone through Biden
they've gone through Warren they've gone
through Sanders they've now gone they're
gonna go through Buddha judge and then
people are gonna start taking a second
look at some of these candidates that's
why common law Harris is desperately
attempting to stay in the race it's why
Cory Booker is staying in the race it's
like Oba Carr is staying in the race
Klobuchar are most of all maybe because
she figures that has a moderate maybe
she will pick up Peabody judges pieces
if Buddha judge should get stomped on by
the media which by the way is incredibly
likely I'll give you the update on that
in just one second first let's talk
about how you can say for the holidays
so literally yesterday I bought some
shirts
for the holidays and as I am checking
out honey this app pops up and it
proceeds to save me like 30 bucks this
happened just yesterday because honey is
great honey is a free browser extension
that automatically finds the best promo
codes whenever you shop online honey has
found over 10 million members over a
billion dollars in savings
honey supports over 20,000 stores online
it works at every site from Amazon to
Express I mean literally all the sites
where you shop you can check them out
through honey if you're buying gifts
this holiday season you need honey if
you're not you probably know someone who
is so do the masala and tell them about
honey it is pretty much free money in
your pocket honey can help make sure
that you are getting the best price for
whatever it is you're buying it's free
to use it installs in just two clicks
get honey for free at join honey calm
slash pen that is join honey calm slash
man again I've been using this browser
extension for probably a couple of years
and I've saved myself thousands of
dollars in in prices I wouldn't need to
pay because of honey honey is just great
check them out of join honey calm sly
friend costs you nothing get honey for
free join honey calm slash man okay so
the media attacks on people who judge
have just begun because the media loved
loved loved Elizabeth Warren and they
are a little bit more split on people to
judge who they don't really understand
the the attack on people who judge has
largely come based on the notion that he
has no appeal to black voters this of
course is true if you look at his
polling numbers among black voters they
absolutely stink there they are awful
they're worse than Bernie Sanders cuz
he's not as famous as Bernie Sanders
they were worse than Elizabeth Warren
who basically had no black support W
kamau Bell who hosted one of the worst
shows on CNN for several years there is
this Travel Show and it was just awful
if you've never been stuck in the
airport watching W kamau Bell talk to
Spring Breakers down in Florida he'll
know what I'm talking about anyway don't
be a camel belle tweeted out we're about
to find out how someone can get less
than zero percent of the black vote why
well because people judge back in 2011
suggested that kids from lower-income
minority neighborhoods don't have
someone they know personally who
testifies to the value of education
which happens to be true
okay disproportionately that is true
that doesn't mean everybody in
low-income minority communities doesn't
testify the value of education it means
that if you have a single-parent
household there are other priorities
very often in that household it does
mean Barack Obama has said this that in
many cases there is a stigma on higher
education
there's a stigma on quote/unquote acting
white hey Rodney Roland fryer over at
over at Harvard University has said
exactly the same thing we talked about a
lot of the statistics on education
yesterday in terms of the education
differential and we also talked about
the fact that if you adjust for income
then what you see is that black women
actually go to college at a higher rate
than white men do so what happened to
the racism what happened to the racism
it turns out that this really is not
about race it is about where you grow up
it is about the culture where you grow
up it is about whether there are a
number of father's in the area not just
a father in the home but a number of
fathers in the area right all of that
matters well people to judge said all
that and then you just got shellacked
but it's gotten a Michael Harriet's over
at the root and went viral yesterday
well now he booted judge called that
Michael Harriet and Michael Harriet
writes this really ridiculous piece
about how he lectured people who to
judge which makes him a hero because
having conversation is one thing but
lecturing somebody is totally great I
mean lecturing somebody when they call
you up is just it shows how strong you
are and it shows how wonderful you are
and you've really added to the debate by
lecturing a presidential candidate who
by the way said something eminently
reasonable that we are all gonna rip him
up and down for right now the praise
that is being received by Michael
Harriet for his writing style again all
it is it is just another sort of tonic
he see Coates James Baldwin knockoff
where you insert random anecdotes that
are supposed to make people feel it's
very purple it's very over-the-top but
because people feel them because they're
a passion that this means that the
writing is good because writing is only
good when it's very passionate not when
it is reason not when there's an actual
argument just when it's very passionate
and when apparently you yell at a
presidential candidate so Michael
Harriet has a follow-up apparently
people who to judge saw his piece
yesterday in which he called people to
judge a lying mf'er and people to judge
called him up which by the way good for
people to judge I've done the same thing
I mean there there are a number of
people who have attacked me over the
years in print I've reached out to them
some of them are jerks I won't name
names some of them have been quite nice
and we've become friendly it's the
people who to judge did the right thing
he called this guy up and this guy
proceeded to lecture people who to judge
and then suggest the people who to judge
is is better in his eyes because he's a
white man who listened it to him and the
piece is really absurd
Michael Harriet says the first thing you
should know about me is that I
absolutely hate talking on the phone
well I think the first thing was you
know about you is that you call people
lying MF errs Bay
and political disagreements that seems
like a pretty good thing to know but he
says my friends family co-workers all
know this about me I'm not the talk it's
not the talking that bothers me it's the
anticipation angst from waiting for a
phone call
therapy and self-reflection have
informed me that my subconscious anxiety
is fueled by the fact that I've received
news of personal and family tragedies
via telephone so over-the-top and people
praising the sort of writing it's just
uh why would you praise this sort of
self-indulgent bullcrap this is also
talking bothers me the second thing you
should know about me is that I will
fight I don't enjoy fighting I don't
even fight very well since Michael
Harriet in fact if I combine my amateur
fist fighting record my jujitsu sparring
all of my slap boxing exhibitions and
the times of Valen Jackson tapped me for
talking smack while running a Boston
Honor in spades my winning percentage is
well below 500 but I believe fisticuffs
are a legitimate way to settle disputes
while arguments are usually pointless
exercises to get one party to proclaim
why the other party is wrong I'd rather
you beat me up so when I received the
text message from South Bend Indiana
mayor Pete bootie judges the
presidential campaign about an article I
wrote I genuinely hoped he was going to
send four or five of his thugs over to
rough me up and that would be it and if
you don't believe that a Peabody judge
supporters out there willing to throw
hands you probably aren't on Twitter I
figured one of his surrogates would
argue with me for a few minutes and I
would continue my day trying to be a
thorn in the side of white supremacy Wow
I mean this guy you know ever puncture
his ego ever
he says the third thing you should know
about me is that I actually keep a small
photo of the mouse from Pinky and the
brain beside my bed that says what are
you gonna do today Michael the answer is
always the same f with white people what
a joy this guy seems I mean really he
seems like an absolute joy so people who
judge calls him up and the first thing
he says is I don't think I've ever been
called a lying MF her before and this
guy says well I thought maybe he does
want to fight and then he starts telling
stories about one time when he had a
cousin who said a thing really that's
completely irrelevant but since he
inserted it in the middle of the piece
it's supposed to have some sort of
deeper meaning and then he gets back to
the conversation he says people would a
judge didn't want to tell me his side of
the story
he didn't excused himself by explaining
that the comments referenced by the
article were made years ago he didn't
even try to explain his plan for black
America I think the context was
important especially the fact that it
was before I took office Budi judge said
but mostly he wanted to listen for 18
minutes and 45 seconds we talked about
educational and equity inequality
poverty and institutional racism in
America and how to fix it okay
I'm lying I don't know how to fix bleep
as I explained to the presidential
candidate for some reason I had two
reflexive refrain from reflexively
calling him mr. president my problem
with his comments was not only that they
were wrong it's that he knows they were
wrong
right this is the part that's that's so
gross about the Michael Harriett attack
is it can't just be a good-faith
disagreement about the sources of
educational inequality and outcome
inequality it has to be that people who
judge is badly motivated that it was all
about Peabody judges actually a person
who has internalized racism and doesn't
even realize it and then Michael Harriet
basically just transcribed all of the
things that he bravely told people to
judge we have to disabuse ourselves from
the notion that the problem with
educational inequality is because of an
esoteric lack of support I explained
that's a lie and a man as educated as
yourself knows it's a lie and to
regurgitate that narrative publicly is
not just dangerous it is malpractice I
conceded he said that the problems with
institutional racism are so complex and
go back so far I'm not sure that anyone
a mayor a governor even a president
could fix them Budi dredge however
insisted there are some things the
people in power could do to make things
more equal a point I actually agreed
with I do think there are some ways to
attack these issues with policies that
might solve these issues but would
certainly help you said but did you
disagree with the point I was making
Buddha judge asked listing a few
programs designed to alleviate this
specific problem sometimes children
don't get to see the possibilities do
you think the lack of positive examples
of educational success can lead to
mistrust and a lack of confidence in the
system no well yes I answered but the
lack of confidence doesn't have anything
to do with role models or support from
parents it's because the bleep is true
right lack of confidence in the
educational system dropping out of
school in high school that's obviously a
reflection of truth as opposed to
Michael Harriet because he discussed in
his column yesterday went to college and
proceeded to get himself a job and
walked the the walks the board walks the
ditch between his lower income side of
town and his school and then he goes on
to talk about how how every study and
data point shows that racism is baked
into the education system well not every
study and data point shows that actually
he says if your goal is to fix the
problem in America's schools why would
you even mention conference a president
can't fix conference and you can't say
black kids don't have confidence in the
system without pointing out all the
reasons they shouldn't have confidence
in the system and then Budi judge agreed
right then Buddha judge did what he's
expected to do he agreed that the Family
Values argument has no
in political discussions because as I
noted it infers that black parents don't
know the importance of a healthy family
structure however the issues that cause
these problems are rooted in poverty
inequality and America's history of
racism so in other words if you get
pregnant out of wedlock like 71 percent
of all of the of the children born in
the black community their parents have
then that is poverty inequality and
systemic racism not you had sex before
being married and then got pregnant
without being married then had a kid
without being married no it's it's it's
got to be about systemic racism the end
of this piece is the is the part that
matters right Michael Harriet says
here's why black voters support black
candidates when you go into a room and
sit around a table of white men we are
worried that this is what will happen
that a room full of white people who
will talk about role models and
conference and crime and no one in the
room will say hold up we can't talk
about any of this without talking about
racism we can't talk about education
without talking about discrimination
that is our fear I have a question if
you just suggested throughout the piece
that you have no solutions to the
problems of racism and discrimination
that those problems are unsolvable right
this is what Michael Harriet himself
says then are you basically just
expecting that politics is a group
therapy session and that it will and
that politics is designed to relieve
people of individual responsibility to
make the decisions that they can make to
make their lives better and then of
course he tell us another story and and
his story is supposed to be very moving
and then he get back it gets back to
Budaj edge and I'll give you the end of
this this ridiculous piece in a second
again the attacks on Budi church are not
going to cease and this particular
attack being cheered on by the
intersectional woked twitter rights it's
ridiculous
this particular attack is an attack on a
perfectly valid point of view the Budi
judge expressed but because he's white
he's not allowed to say it I'll get to
that in just one second first let's talk
about the quality of your bedding so if
you are lacking in sleep quality this
holiday season maybe have a great
mattress maybe everyone got one maybe
everything in your room is is sleep set
right you don't have the blue light
right before you go to sleep but you're
still not getting the sleep you need
perhaps that has something to do with
the sheets upon which you are sleeping
this is why you need Boleyn branch but
when brown sheets are so good that I got
rid of literally all the other sheets in
my house and we only use Boleyn branch
everything Boleyn branch makes from
bedding to blankets is made from pure
100% organic cotton they start out super
soft they get even softer over time we
buy directly from them so your
essentially paying wholesale prices
luxury sheets can cost up to a thousand
bucks in the store but bowl and branch
sheets are only a couple of hundred
bucks shipping is free you can try them
for 30 nights there's no risk no reason
not to give them a try tribal and branch
sheets you will indeed love them to get
you started right now my listeners get
50 bucks off your first set of sheets at
bol and branch comm promo code Ben go to
bull and branch comm today for 50 bucks
off your first set of sheets that is bol
and branch com promo code Ben bull and
branch comm promo code
Ben so good you're gonna get rid of all
the other sheets in your house Bo and
branch comm promo code Ben and get 50
bucks off your first set of sheets okay
so this article from Michael Harriette
which is again the second of a two-part
series the first calling people to
gentle lying mf'er ii basically saying
that he is a nice white man meaning he
has no ability to change anything but at
least he listens to me he says people
judges a white man I didn't say it like
that I told him he was obviously
intelligent I told him he was lucky to
have all the privileges he was afforded
I told him it was clear that he was
hardworking but I said you're a white
man a mediocre white kid with mediocre
intelligence and mediocre parents can
easily make it in America I explained
blackly and this is exactly the parallel
to when he suggested that Buddha judges
talk about education was Buddha judge
explaining Whitely right see see it's
not that he is saying something right or
wrong it's that he is saying something
from a black perspective and therefore
it is inherently correct and that is the
point that Harriet is making is it a
smart black kid with smart parents and a
supportive community still has to fight
every day to hope to reach the levels of
what a mediocre white man accomplishes
okay first of all untrue if you want to
say a black male then perhaps you have
more statistical support if you want to
say black kid false as I just mentioned
black women who grow up in similar
circumstances to white women actually do
better than white women in terms of
income and college education black men
have a different problem in fact black
men growing up in the top 1% a family
household income are still as likely to
be arrested as a white kid growing up at
$36,000 level of income that is not due
to systemic systemics criminal justice
racism that's that's that's a bigger
problem than the Hat okay that is
personal behavior because people aren't
being arrested just for the sake of
being arrested but this notion that if
you are black you are inherently behind
the eight-ball in the United States no
matter what decisions you make no matter
what decisions you make or the household
you grow up in the data are just not
there to
to support that and then Harriet
concludes he says the only thing I
actually know about people who judges
that he is a white man which is the most
racist statement ever right I mean
that's truly racist to suggest that all
you know about people who judge not what
he has said about his policies not what
his record has been again you're turning
into a Peabody Judge supporter here or a
defender here because the left is so
rampantly ridiculous here he says the
only thing I actually know about people
who judge is that he is a white man
because he says as I told the mayor the
article wasn't meant to inspire outrage
its purpose was to make a necessary
point about black voters and real issues
there is no way I can know if he is
genuinely interested in engaging black
voters attacking discrimination or
crossing the racial divide there are an
infinite number of candidates who have
waded into black barber shops or
sashayed into black pulpits to assure us
that they were on our side when they
were only interested in our vote I'm not
smart repressions enough to tell the
difference but you suggested earlier in
the article that black voters support
black candidates because you do know by
the color of their skin that they're not
just there to live off your vote he says
the only thing I actually know about
people who judge is that he has a white
man but people to judge listen which is
all you can ask a white man to do unless
of course he wants to fight that's all
you can ask a white man to do is listen
because he's just a white guy guys this
is such a racist take on America but it
is being echoed on Twitter this was this
article too was trending on Twitter it's
you're not gonna solve any of the
problems that plagued the educational
system if your first move is to declare
that anyone who calls out problems you
don't like is somehow endemic of white
racism and that the only thing you can
talk about according Michael Harry is
exactly the stuff that you can't solve
it's just it's an absurdity it piled on
an absurdity but this is part of a
broader media attack on Budaj edge by
the way Huffington Post which has been
openly supporting Elizabeth Warren at
this point they launched another attack
on Budaj edge over the last 24 hours
attacking his super PAC according to
Huffington Post his PAC dubbed hitting
home was designed to mobilize resources
to elect Democrats at every level and in
communities both red and blue who will
put the lived experiences of Americans
front and center and he said that they
would support candidates focusing on
showing voters what we are for not just
what we are against in 2020 butI judge
shut down the group or when he started
his race the pack had done pretty much
nothing to help Democrats to him in 2018
midterm elections of the slightly more
than $400,000 booty judge raised for the
pack it donated just 37 thousand dollars
to other Democratic candidates at the
same time the PAC paid nearly 70 grand
to Liz Smith who served as buddha'
judges spokesperson and became the
communications director for his
presidential bid another 30 grand went
to Michael Shmuel who served as the
packs treasurer and is now a booty judge
campaign manager the packs financials
director received 34 grand a top
Democratic media consulting firm was
paid 28 grand the PAC helped the Buddha
judge catapult from a well credentialed
mayor of 100,000 population college
council leading contender for the
nation's highest office Buddha judge
suggested that the PAC slow rate of
support for other Democrats was because
of a failure to raise money some of the
PACs in admin costs were similar to
those of other presidential contenders
he's been about 77 grand on accountants
compliance legal fees Biden spent 67
grand Kamala Harris's group spent 90
grand but the the PAC what was not
exactly doing what it was billed to do
so huffington post coming after pete
booty judge as well now meanwhile the
Democrats may beginning to realize that
they do in fact have to tack to the
center if they hope to win the 2020
election because the fact is that they
have moved far too radical and he knows
leading that charge Barack Obama we'll
get to that in just one second first do
you have a bunch of pictures that are
sitting at your house and they need
frames but the fact is that if you go
down to the local frame shop it's gonna
cost you an absolute fortune well good
news for you frame bridge makes it easy
and affordable to frame at your favorite
things from art prints and posters to
all your best photos and with the
holidays fast approaching frame bridge
is a perfect way to give ridiculously
easy and thoughtful gifts here's how it
works you go to frame bridge calm you
upload your photo you can preview your
ID item online in a variety of frame
styles or select one of their
best-selling designs the expert team at
the frame fat frame bridge Factory
will then custom frame ur item and
deliver the finished piece straight to
you or to anyone on your list
a handmade personalized gift from frame
bridge starts at 39 bucks all shipping
is free my listeners will get 15% off
their first order at frame bridge comm
when they use my promo code Shapiro's
I've used frame bridge before they make
it supremely easy and again it's not
going to cost you an arm and a leg to
basically get stuff custom framed it's
pretty
some become a gift-giving legend use
frame bridge to have high quality
one-of-a-kind gifts that you can order
in minutes go to frame bridge calm use
promo code Shapiro you'll save an
additional 15% off your first order just
go to frame bridge calm promo code
Shapiro again frame bridge calm promo
code Shapiro okay meanwhile the
Democrats are beginning to realize that
they have swung too far to the
leprechaun
of all people is telling Democrats that
they've swung too far to the left
Politico had an article yesterday in
which Barack Obama's aides were quoted
as saying that Obama might have stepped
in in the middle of this presidential
race to stop Bernie Sanders if he
thought Sanders was gonna be the nominee
according to Ryan Liz's report over at
Politico back when Sanders seemed like
more of a threat than he does now Obama
said privately that if Bernie were
running away with the nomination Obama
would speak up to stop him
one adviser told Lizza he can't confirm
that he hasn't said that directly to me
said the advisor the only reason I'm
hesitating at all is because yeah if
Bernie were running away with it I think
maybe we'd all have to say something but
I don't think that's likely it's not
happening so the Democrats beginning to
realize that the full scale embrace of
Medicare for all democratic socialism is
not going to be a successful strategy
this is particularly true in the swing
states really interesting article by
Nate Cohen and Claire Miller
over at the New York Times today called
they voted Democrat now they support
Trump talking about how in 2018 a bunch
of people who had supported Trump in
voted for the Democrats and now they are
swinging back to trump for 2020
according to the New York Times success
in the midterms might not mean as much
for Democratic presidential candidates
as the party might think nearly
two-thirds of voters in six battleground
states who voted for Trump in 2016 but
for Democratic congressional candidates
in 2018 say they intend to back the
president's against each of his top
rivals according to recent polling by
the New York Times upshot Siena College
the results suggest the party's winning
formula in last year's midterm elections
may not be so easy to replicate in a
presidential election the Democrats
relatively moderate house candidates
succeeded in large part by flipping a
crucial segment of voters who backed the
president in 2016
if those voters remain open-minded again
in 2020 Democrats will have a ready-made
blueprint for winning back the crucial
Rust Belt a battleground the group is
only a sliver of the electorate 2% of
registered voters not representative of
all voters they're overwhelmingly white
60% are male two-thirds have no college
degree but the president strength among
them helps explain why he is highly
competitive in States the Democrats
carried just
one year ago many of the voters who said
they voted Democrat but now intended to
vote for Trump offered explanations that
reflect long-standing theories about why
the party out of power tends to excel in
midterms so for example some of these
Democrats who people voted Democrat in
2018 suggested that congressional
Democrats had pledged to bring jobs back
some of them had sought to balance out
Trump by electing as they are splitting
the ticket they're voting Democrat for
Congress but but Republican for the
presidency and it turns out that a lot
of these people just believe that the
that the Democrats have lost touch with
the generic swing state voter some
voters say they are preparing to take
the leap to vote for Trump after
supporting both Democratic congressional
candidates in 2018 and Hillary Clinton
2016 in the survey from the New York
Times 7% of people who supported Clinton
in 2016
said they now approved of the
president's performance despite his
personality and his Twitter account
according to giuliana California 57 a
nurse from Coral Springs Florida she
said in 2016 I hated both candidates I
went with Hillary because Trump had no
history as a politician she said he's
not exactly the person I'd have is my
best friend of Trump but he's a great
president most politicians just talk
about doing things but Trump actually
does things people on the Democratic
side also like Trump's talk about the
unions and trade so in other words Trump
is running pretty durable in the swing
states that he actually needs to win
which is pretty fascinating one of the
reasons why you're seeing Democrats
embracing an electoral level Biden budda
judge right Biden boo to judge the
support level for those two candidates
is far greater than the support level
for Warren and Sanders in the latest
polling data which means that the left
wing of the party is actually losing
again and there's a reason for that
because the fact is Democrats understand
that if Trump runs against the radical
left of the party he's likely to win and
President Trump today rally last night
and he made the case against the
Democrats and it is a very good case
here as president Trump free speech free
assembly religious liberty and the right
to keep and bear arms and above all we
will never stop fighting for the sacred
values that bind us together as one
beautiful country as one America okay I
mean that pitch is a better pitch than
the Democrats Medicare for all drag
queens will take down Trump right there
the more radical wing of the Democratic
Party like that that stuff is not going
to play particularly in the swing states
which is one of the reasons why Michael
Bloomberg is even throwing his hat into
the race we'll get to Michael Bloomberg
in just one second first let's talk
about how hye-rin can be a challenge I
mean the fact is that you're constantly
looking to upgrade your business so
let's say the other producer like say a
producer named Mike and let's say that
one of his only jobs before the show is
to ensure that the microphone that is
strung up your shirt so that you can
actually speak into the microphone is
there and then you start the show and
then you realize that the microphone is
not on your shirt and let's say you're
like you know what Mike this has
happened one too many times I don't care
that you play a great bass guitar I am
NOT okay with this it's time to upgrade
our producers well then perhaps you
would look to I'm not that's just an
example I'm not saying it actually
happened that way then you should check
out zip recruiter com zipper crew makes
things supremely easy well what do they
do first
they they post your job and then
basically they invite people who are
qualified to apply for your job so you
get qualified candidates fast with
results like that it's no wonder that
four out of five employers who post on
zip recruiter get a quality candidate
within the very first day CY zip
recruiters effective for businesses of
all sizes
try zip recruiter for free at this web
address zip recruiters accom slash daily
wire that zip recruiter comm slash Dai
ly WI re zip recruiter com slash
daily wire zip recruiter is indeed the
smartest way to hire ok before we go any
further I also have to remind you of
something I'm about to say something I
never thought I would say you ready for
this do not buy a membership to daily
wired today don't do it today
why because I'm going to save you some
money this Friday is Black Friday I had
some daily wire insider information
about some amazing deals for you hold on
to your money now wait until Friday for
the best deal we have ever offered in
the history of the daily wire you will
thank me later and then you should
subscribe on Friday around just hold off
do it on Friday and then once you're a
subscriber you get our articles ad free
you get access to all of our live
broadcasts our full show library select
bonus content our exclusive daily water
app which is a pretty fantastic feature
if you have not yet checked it out plus
if you choose the new All Access plan
you get all of that plus the legend
I left his tears tumblr and our brand
new asked me anything style discussion
feature that allows you to engage our
hosts writers and special guests on a
weekly basis again wait until Friday for
the best deal we have ever offered you
will thank me later
also one of the reasons you should
subscribe you get our Sunday special on
Saturday this Sunday's special we have
an overload of yarmulkes because
stopping by is Yoram has oniy the
scholar on nationalism has a great book
out about the virtue of nationalism and
a lot of nationalism talk lately we had
rich Lowry on there having your own
hezonia onions a really interesting
thinker so you're gonna want to check
that out here's a little bit what it
sounded like
okay I live in a socialist country no
one dislikes socialism as much as I do
it's totally intolerable I don't want
anybody to live like that I don't want
Americans to live like that I'm not on
that side but if they're gonna tell me
that economics which is the science of
the choosing free consenting individual
can answer the basic problems America
has today that's false say your MS a
really really interesting thinker I
really enjoy his work also a personal
friend so it's it's pretty cool and
interesting discussion so you get all of
those wonderful things also again day
after Thanksgiving buy the subscription
then go daily we're calm / subscribe and
make the magic happen for yourself it
really is fantastic we're the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
you
so does because the Democrats are
beginning to realize they've skewed too
far to the left that Michael Bloomberg
is jumping in the race what exactly is
his strategy while he's gonna skip Iowa
he's in a skip New Hampshire he's gonna
skip all the early states and he's gonna
skip the debates Sean Trent has an
interesting piece over at Real Clear
Politics in which he basically says that
what Bloomberg is betting is that Biden
might get knocked out early and then
Bloomberg becomes sort of the moderate
choice to supplant Biden if Biden starts
to drop in the polls
Sean Trend says if Bloomberg were to
enter early contests who'd become an
immediate threat his opponents would
take shots at him for all of the above
mentioned issues right all of his
running of New York and stop and frisk
and all that kind of stuff if he avoids
the scrum Biden has finite resources and
has to decide whether to spend five
million bucks attacking Bloomberg who's
waiting in the wings or to spend that
five million dollars attacking Elizabeth
Warren or Pia Buddha judge that seems
like an easy choice
again while Bloomberg is largely being
annoyed by ignored by his competitors he
can define himself in later states sean
friend who's an elections analyst over
at real club politics he says whoever
emerges from the first floor contest is
likely to be bloodied and perhaps cap
strapped cash-strapped it is even
possible it will be Sanders and Warren
who stagger out of South Carolina at
that point if Biden has tanked in Iowa
and New Hampshire Bloomberg is the only
viable option for Democratic moderates
and establishment liberals this probably
won't work but Bloomberg can easily drop
500 million bucks on this race and still
live out the rest of his years quite
comfortably there's a chance the Stars
will align and he becomes the next
president of the US it isn't a
particularly bad bet to make that is why
Michael Bloomberg is sticking around
it's why you're saying all the other
Democrats sticking around they're
figuring that with all the attacks on
Buddha judge boo judge is likely to drop
in the polls sometime in the near future
meanwhile controversy breaks out at the
White House over the stupidest possible
topic so we are big fans of Conan the
dog big fans of corn on the dog here at
the Daily wire we created a meme that
President Trump then tweeted out it was
a picture of a president Trump giving
the medal of pawner had a paw on it to
Conan Conan of course is the dog that
chased down Abu Bakr al Baghdadi but
then blew himself up in a tunnel the dog
was slightly wounded and is now fine so
Trump had him to the White House
yesterday and this turned into a major
controversy because the White House
claimed that Conan was a boy but the
Pentagon suggested that Conan was a girl
and the media went nuts over this and
went nuts over this they then suggested
that the White House and the Pentagon
had changed their story to match I'm not
kidding
to match the White House's take on all
of this so you had journalists blue
checkmarks reporting hot news on Conan's
gender Luis Martinez over at ABC update
to the cone and gender another US
defense official now says for sure that
cone and the hero dog is a male based on
multiple internal checks Sean Robertson
Fox had suggested that there had to be
regular updates his Nocona and his
female again according to some reports
then one photo I've seen of the relevant
area definitely looks like the dog has
lady parts but the resolution admittedly
is not great she had all of these
reporters who were checking into the
genitals of the dog which by the way is
not the way I've been informed by the
people who know in the scientific
community I've been informed by folks
who know that that is not the way you
check the gender of a dog you ask the
dog you you have to check the dog's
gender and/or species identity because
gender and sex are completely different
and perhaps the dog feels like a female
dog even if it is a biologically male
dog so just looking at the general that
is the sex assigned at Birth to the dog
let's not be in any way intolerant on
this particular issue well Kelly and
Conway decided to play a game with the
press yesterday they asked her about the
gender of the dog and she simply refused
to answer the question which is quite
hilarious here she was yesterday we just
gave you definitively say the sex no I
won't do that because then you'll say
that I was talking about somebody's sex
or gender so this prompted in actual
editorial piece from Molly Roberts at
The Washington Post called how the White
House ruined the hero dog now I'm pretty
sure it's you guys who were in the hero
dog because everybody was pretty much on
board with the hero dog and then you
guys started in fact checking whether or
not the President of the United States
had actually given a medal to the hero
dog like three weeks ago and then Trump
has the dog there and you start moaning
of it you start bitching and moaning
about why the president wasn't nice
enough to the hero dog and how there was
a big controversy over over the sex of
the dog I definitely trust you guys on
these issues like I think that by the
way do I really think that the media
even care about facts no I don't I think
that they have an agenda I think it's
pretty obvious they have an agenda
speaking of which my friend Andy no
who's been a guest on the radio show
several times he was suspended from
Twitter on Monday why well he posted
statistically accurate information about
transgender violence against
transgenders in the United States in
response to former first daughter
Chelsea Clinton according to Amanda
presto giacomo over at Daily wire no
posted in a tweet that earned him a
suspension the u.s. is one of the safest
countries for trans people the murder
rate of trans victims is actually lower
than that for the Syst population also
who is behind the murders mostly black
men he was suspended for this he was
suspended from Twitter for this because
journalism in guys because if you
actually state aced a statistically
verifiable fact you must be banned from
Twitter if that statistically verifiable
fact is offensive this is the direction
we are now moving the the media
fact-checking the genitals of dogs and
twitter banning people who state
statistically verifiable statements
about violence against transgender
people in the United States know was who
notified by Twitter that he had been
suspended for violating the tech giant's
rule against so-called hateful content
no said in a statement quote stating a
verifiable empirical claim with no value
judgment attached is determined to be
hateful conduct by Twitter the platform
mostly used by journalists to
communicate and counter fake news also
actively punishes individuals for
communicating truths when they are
deemed a politically inconvenient this
was no had posted this in response to
hello to Chelsea Clinton writing since
2013 more than a hundred and fifty trans
people have been murdered in the US the
majority black transgender women on
transgender day transgender rights day
in 2019 transgender Day of Remembrance
2019 we remember and honor the lives
lost hold their loves one in our hearts
and must commit to doing all we can to
end this epidemic of violence and hate
the statistical information provided by
no is actually also provided by the
Human Rights Commission the same
organization that Clinton centered for
transgender Day of Remembrance tweet
around I mean Chad Felix Green who has
outlined this in the Federalist he says
of the 118 cases listed from 2015 to
2019 52 have known murderers the above
chart reveals that the racial identity
of the victim and the murderer seem
entirely irrelevant to the murder
motivation while 67 percent of the
victims are NZ black and the majority
are trans women as reported the majority
of their killers are black as well this
is true for white victims and a single
Native American victim who was murdered
by a Native American killer it's not
shocking of course
that that no was banned from Twitter
because this is the same platform that
banned feminist writer Megan Murphy for
suggesting that men are men and women
are women yes fact rule the day in the
world of social media as well as in the
media as well speaking of bad media
coverage there's an absurd article about
same-sex relationship same-sex behavior
and animals according to the New York
Times and just shows you how science is
becoming secondary to politics there's
an article in the New York Times called
seeking a new lens to study same-sex
behavior in animals a team of
researchers say that science has relied
on a human heterosexual baseline and
made faulty assumptions about sexual
activity in the animal kingdom how so
well it turns out that homosexual
activity is not supremely uncommon in
the animal kingdom which so what I mean
really so what but the question that has
been asked by a variety of researchers
of all political stripes has been okay
so why does homosexual behavior continue
to occur in the animal kingdom
considering that it is not on its face
evolutionarily beneficial right a
homosexual activity does not produce
offspring obviously and so if you're
talking about the value of evolutionary
evolutionary biology and carrying on
genetic lineage then why would you
engage in why would there be a
continuation of same-sex behavior in
animals when this obviously does not
forward the genetic profile of the
animals at issue and so there been a
bunch of theories the idea that this is
this create some sort of bonding between
animals or the idea that this is this is
some sort of this is some sort of
altruistic that animals that are
oriented this way provided some old sort
of altruistic service to other young
offspring in the community right they're
a bunch of been a bunch of biological
theories about this but the New York
Times is angry at all of those
biological theories why because they say
it is heterosexist the origins of such
same section sexual behavior have long
puzzled evolutionary biologists how
could this behavior evolve and persist
in so many lineages even when it doesn't
directly aid reproduction says the New
York Times that very question may be the
wrong one to ask a group of researchers
argue in a study published last week in
Nature ecology and evolution seeking to
flip the underlying assumptions of a
whole wing of biology Ambika cometh a
researcher at the University of
California Berkeley and co-author on the
study says the expectation has been that
same-sex sexual behavior evolved in
different species independently
against this default background of
heterosexual sex and what we're saying
is that the baseline isn't necessarily
the right baseline instead the
researchers suggest that same-sex
behavior is bound up in the very origins
of animal sex it hasn't had to
continually revolve it's always been
there but that doesn't answer why it has
remained right because if there is
behavior that is evolutionarily
non-sustainable then why exactly would
it remain right this has been the
mystery that has puzzled evolutionary
biologists but the fact that people even
asked the question is apparently
cisnormative according to the New York
Times evolutionary biologists have long
pondered same-sex behavior often
describing it as a Darwinian paradox
Paul vase 'i'm an expert on non
conceptive sexuality at the University
of Lethbridge in Alberta who didn't
participate in the study says one school
of thought how that such behaviors
weren't primarily sexual instead
relating to dominance or grooming other
researchers have suggested it persists
in some species because it helps social
animals maintain communities according
to max Lambert a biologist at Berkeley
so others suggested that examples of
same-sex behavior were practice for
reproductive sex or even cases of
mistaken identity most agreed it had to
have some sort of evolutionary benefit
to make up for the presumed cost of non
reproductive sexual behavior but this
study says no one of the authors julia
monk a PhD candidate at Yale and the
study's lead lead author says the idea
that same-sex sexual behavior had to be
justified at all seemed like a
perspective of dominant cultural norms
rather than a more holistic view of the
actual biology I really disagreed with
some of the ways I saw that discussion
framed so what exactly are these
researchers looking for they are looking
to bring into the conversation gender
theorists not kidding at issue with past
research in the field dr. Lambert says
that unexamined unexamined cultural
projections largely by the white
heterosexual men who have dominated the
field resulted in many researchers
failing to accurately document what they
were seeing
you see there's too many white
heterosexual male scientists and that's
why they asked the question why sexual
behavior that obviously and explicitly
cannot lead to reproduction continues to
maintain in the animal kingdom
so the question itself is a reflection
of the patriarchy not a reflection of an
actual biological mystery miss monk and
her colleagues say that explicitly
flipping the cultural assumptions in
this case by conducting the study with
researcher
who self-identify as queer and bringing
in outside disciplines like social
science can yield the better research ah
see that'll change that we have to
change the science by bringing in
scientists who are gay because they will
have a vested stake in the notion that
the underlying patterns of sexual
behavior are homosexual in origin and
therefore that will change the entire
script of course none of this actually
answers the question but they're saying
that the question is irrelevant but it's
only being asked because people are
heterosexual which again does not
explain the Darwinian evolution of
homosexual behavior and animals and its
continued maintenance but again see even
ask that question is apparently
heterosexist that the whole thing is
it's just absurd speaking of scientific
absurdity there's a piece today again
from the Washington Post talking about
the fact that Americans are continuing
to die young at rather alarming rates
America's life expectancy dropped for
the third consecutive year according to
the Washington Post death rates from
suicide drug overdoses at liver disease
and dozens of other causes have been
rising over the past decade for young
and middle-aged adults driving down
overall life expectancy in the United
States for three consecutive years
according to a strikingly bleak study
published Tuesday that looked at the
past six decades of mortality data the
report published in the Journal of
America of the American Medical
Association JAMA which is a pretty
prestigious journal was immediately
hailed by outside researchers for its
comprehensive treatment of a still
enigmatic trend the reversal of
historical patterns in longitude II
despite spending more on health care
than any other country the US has seen
increasing mortality and following life
expectancy for people aged 25 to 64 who
should be in the prime of their lives
which has nothing to do with the health
care system and everything to do with
suicide opioid epidemic and obesity and
the single greatest factor in this in
this particular study is obesity and it
is buried way down in the article way
down in the article according to one of
the analysts who is looking at the study
Stephen wolf who's director I'm a
rightist of the Center on society and
health at Virginia Commonwealth
University he says some of it may be due
to obesity some of it may be due to drug
addiction some of it may be due to
distracted driving from cellphones given
the breadth and pervasiveness of the
trend it suggests that the cause has to
be systemic that there's some root cause
that's causing adverse health across
many different dimensions for working
age adults now listen I wrote an entire
book suggesting that
rise in the opioid epidemic and the and
the increase in suicide is at least
partially due to a lack of meaning that
Americans are feeling each and every day
but beyond that the most obvious medical
explanation for all of this be on drug
overdose is obesity
obesity has been rampant according to
the Washington Post burying this all the
way down in the in the middle of the
story I'm in like paragraph 15 obesity
is a significant part of the story the
average woman in the United States today
weighs as much as the average man did
half a century ago whoa men now weigh
about thirty pounds more than that most
people in the United States are
overweight an estimated seventy one
point six percent of the population age
20 and older according to the CDC that
figure includes 39.8% who are obese 44
in 10 Americans over age 20 are obese
which means having a body mass index of
30 or higher in adults obesity is also
rising in children nearly 19% of the
population aged 2 to 19 is obese Jay
Olshansky professor of public health at
the University of Illinois in Chicago
says these kids are acquiring obesity in
their early teen years sometimes under
the age of 10 when they get into their
20s 30s and 40s they are carrying the
risk factors of obesity that were
required when they were children we
didn't see that in previous generations
he says this isn't a one-time phenomenon
it's gonna echo through time in other
words people are eating too much the
reason I bring this up is because this
is buried all the way down there in the
article pass factors like drugs or the
healthcare system if we eat ourselves to
death and die at age 50 that's going to
really skew the life expectancy
statistics in the United States and
these are the same members of the media
who in the Style section will be pushing
the idea that you can be healthy at
anyway which is obviously untrue
obviously untrue this has been one of
the big pushes in social media is you're
beautiful no matter what weight you are
well beautiful it is is an aesthetic
judgment right it's subjective and
aesthetic to a certain extent and then
beyond a certain extent it is not I
think there there is such a thing as
objective beauty in the sense that
pretty much everybody agrees what is
beautiful and what is not but beauty is
to a certain extent in the eye of the
beholder what is not in the eye of the
beholder is your health status and the
idea that you are healthy at anyway is
simply untrue there's not a single
serious medical professional in the
United States will suggest that you are
healthy at any weight and the media is
prevailing
sentiment that you are healthy at any
weight is again anti-scientific the
anti-scientific tilt of the media and
increasingly the scientists themselves
is an extraordinarily dangerous
phenomenon in the United States it is it
is going to lead to severe consequences
is going to lead to people leading less
healthy lives is going to lead to the
skewing of science in crucial areas of
American life and then we are told of
course that if we question the anti
scientific consensus then we are anti
science in some way political
correctness should never trump the
ability of people to live healthy lives
and what we are seeing right now is
exactly that ok time for a couple of
quick things that I like and then a
couple of quick things that I hate so
first of all things I like Thanksgiving
is coming up I love Thanksgiving
Thanksgiving is phenomenal so first I
just want to give thanks to you the
listener you guys make it all possible I
really appreciate you engaging with our
content every single day it is awesome
to be able to speak to you and to have
this conversation with you on an ongoing
basis honestly thanks to our staff our
staff is aside from once you get fired
during every sip recruiter ad our staff
are just phenomenal they do an amazing
job each and every day dealing with my
ridiculousness and vicissitudes and
arriving late for each and every
broadcast they do a great job here at
the Daily wire I want to thank the
administrators heard the daily where
they do a great job of insuring you we
have great staff making sure that all of
the trains run on time obviously want to
thank my family I'm thankful for my
family which provides the support basis
and also the duty that makes me a better
person
I want to thank specifically obviously
my wife and my kids who are wonderful in
every way I know it sounds like an Oscar
speech but since Thanksgiving coming up
sounds like good time to say what I'm
thankful for and I am thankful for the
Declaration of Independence and the
Constitution of the United States the
greatest documents ever written by man
these documents enshrine basic notions
of human individual rights and Liberty
the value of each individual human being
those eternal principles spelled out in
those documents not fulfilled at the
founding but gradually broadened to
encompass everyone they should encompass
over time that is the legacy of the
United States I could not be more
grateful to live in this phenomenal
phenomenal country okay one other thing
that I like so guy named Scott Alexander
is a magician and I have to say I'm a
big fan of close-up magic so I love
sleight of hand I just think that it is
spectacular I think that it is it's an
incredible skill set I mean it's it's
not like you know big magic tricks don't
do it for me like the David Copperfield
because once
you know how the trick is done you could
do the trick I could do the trick but
the guys who do sleight of hand these
are people who practice hours a day to
develop an actual craft and it really is
very cool well Scott Alexander magician
he it turns out is a big fan of the show
and has our leftist terrace tumbler and
sent me a tape of himself performing a
magic trick about impeachment using our
leftist heroes tumblr is why I should
subscribe so you can actually see this
thing because it ain't gonna sound as
good as it looks
here's Scott Alexander performing some
magic with the leftist eros tumbler now
the left is hoping that they're going to
end up with a great big juicy
impeachment in the house yeah that's a
peach but that could be just an illusion
what's more likely is that they'll end
up with a lemon in the Senate now I
don't know which is going to happen but
the thing that I don't understand is
mainly how this vessel itself this
magical vessel was able to be used in
this little demonstration of sleight of
hand when it has the power to constantly
be full of tears
check that yeah that's cool stuff okay
so as a big magic man thanks Scott
really appreciate it and you should go
check out his work you can see a lot of
his work on YouTube Scott Alexander had
some pretty cool stuff okay time for a
quick thing that I hate so colin
kaepernick he posted a video complaining
about his fate because he did this
ridiculous workout right so the NFL
specifically set up a workout for him so
that he could work out for all of the
teams and he ditched the workouts and he
didn't want to do the workout and he did
his own workout apparently won that
great and then he talked about what a
hero he was he then released a video
online talking about his fate and it was
a defiant message to the NFL which he
says his banning him which of course is
not true nobody wants him because one he
is not even a mediocre quarterback at
this point and number two he's giant
pain in the ass and so he posted a video
talking about how terrible his life is
because the NFL has victimized him well
he earns a million bucks for kneeling
for the national anthem which is about
as ungrateful as it gets on Thanksgiving
two owners 32 teams roger goodell all of
them to stop running stop running from
the truth
stop running from the keep we'll let you
know if we hear from men both in their
Court were ready to go okay so he posted
this clipped up video of himself talking
about this with some cool music and some
pictures and self signing autographs
okay well the the I will say one thing
I'm grateful for this is hilarious so
Colin Kaepernick didn't get any interest
none but Jordan VZ was one of his wide
receivers from the workout and has now
earned an opportunity to tryout with the
Cleveland Browns according to heavy comm
according to Howard Bowser VZ was among
the six players the Browns worked out on
Monday he played college football in
California he has not yet found a
long-term NFL home he's been on the
practice squads for the Titans Jags
Colts and most recently the Buffalo
Bills who's released in October from
Buffalo unlikely that anything comes
from the tryout but pretty hilarious
that dude showed up for Colin
Kaepernick's for Colin Kaepernick's
tryout and Colin Kaepernick didn't get a
tryout with any of the teams but one of
his receivers did that is that is pretty
hysterical and I kind of love it
okay final thing that I hate okay so
it's Thanksgiving season that means
you're gonna have to talk with your
annoying uncle or aunt how about this
how about just have like a nice
conversation and if it's not going well
just don't talk politics I'm constantly
amazed a number of articles that come
out how to talk to your crazy right-wing
uncle
hey how about you just don't talk
politics at the table if you can't
handle it like really if you can't
handle it my favorite is that the
national network of abortion funds put
out a tweet talking about how you should
bring your abortion toolkit to dinner
what in case you can't cover the turkey
and run outta rays you run out of
scalpels you need the abortion toolkit
at dinner if you're talking about at
Thanksgiving you're doing Thanksgiving
wrong guys just suffice it to say I
think that that is obviously the case
already we'll be back here later today
with two additional hours otherwise we
will see you after Thanksgiving make
sure by the way that if you're gonna
subscribe you do it on Friday Black
Friday we got an amazing deal for you so
tune in then I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Rebecca Dodd poets directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producers Mathis Glover and Robert
Stirling technical producer Austin
Stephens associate producer Colton Haas
assistant director Pavel why douse key
edited by Adam Sai events audio is mixed
by mic Romina hair and makeup is by
Joshua alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew Clavin
[Music]